welcome to book TV's afterwards i'm sam
Tanenhaus editor of the New York Times
Book Review and my guest today is Alan
Brinkley distinguished historian an
author of a new biography of Henry Luce
welcome Alan you're one of the most
distinguished political historians in
America why did you choose to write a
biography of a famous journalist well
it's a long story and I will hopefully
tell you all of it I I was interested in
writing a biography after I finished my
last book which is on the New Deal and I
was sort of groping around for a I
didn't want to write about a president I
didn't and I think partly because I'm
from a family of journalists the idea of
writing about journalism appealed to me
my father David Brinkley was a
television news man my brother was a New
York Times reporter for many years my
younger brother was a Scripps Howard
reporter
my mother was a United Press reporter
for a while in her youth so I'm the only
one who's never been in journalism and
that probably led me to it's also I was
sort of encouraged to do it by a few
people including Arthur Schlesinger who
thought a wonderful historian a great
friend and he he thought Luce had never
had a good biography and that so that
helped me and then I just decided to
poke around in the archives for a little
bit to see whether I wanted to do it and
the material was so rich and so
revealing that it really made me excited
about writing his biography your book is
called the publisher Henry Luce and his
American Century
explain that subtitle
well the American century is a phrase
that that is best known because of an
essay that Luce wrote in 1941 and that
phrase is echoed through the decades
since then making it his American
Century rather than the American Century
is sort of my I guess a fairly subtle
way of suggesting that the American
Century that Luce envisioned didn't
actually happen that it was a vision but
not a reality that vision was a vision
of the United States as the great model
in to the world of what the future would
be and that the future after World War
two would be America spreading the the
good news of America around the world
and reshaping the world as a result and
of course as we see now that effort
among other things created a lot of ill
will around the world and has produced
some of the the problems that we're
living with today Alan this suggests
there was a missionary or crusading
impulse to Henry Luce tell us about his
background was a missionary quality to
loose and for good reason his father was
a Presbyterian missionary in China Luce
was born there he grew up there
he was immersed in the missionary life
and in China where there were very few
conversions to Christianity
the missionaries sort of gave up on
evangelizing and recruiting new new
Christians and turned themselves into
people who were trying to modernize
China and to educate and to create a
sort of modern world in China that was
certainly what his father believed in
and Luce believed in it too
now loose was educated or received much
of his education in very elite
institutions in America this is one of
the themes of your book he was born I
believe in 1898 and when did he come to
America to study and where did he study
he left well he he went to boarding
school in China British boarding school
which he hated but which was a very
rigorous even if if almost cruel a
school that prepared him very well and
he left China at the age of 13 and
traveled to Europe spent a year in
Europe as part of it at a school in
England and part of it traveling and
then went to Hotchkiss at the age of 14
and school in Connecticut in Connecticut
lakeville Connecticut are actually 15 I
guess when he was he would begin
Hotchkis he was a scholarship student
which was a kind of demeaning position
within the school but he paid no
attention to the assumption that
scholarship students were somehow
inferior and he housing out at the
beginning no we had to live you know in
a house where away away from the campus
and take a take a truck in every morning
but he he treated Koch kiss as if he
were one of the elite and ultimately of
course became one what kind of student
was he he was a very good student he was
a brilliant student in fact always
number one number two in his class that
was true in China as well he was a if he
had chosen to be an academic he would
have been a brilliant academic I was
surprised to learn from your book how we
kept he was at foreign languages
ancient Greek he won the the Yale prize
for the best Greek scholar in his
freshman year because of the because of
how well he had learned Greek in at
Hotchkis it was kind of a breeding
ground or grooming school for Yale
students is that right almost everyone
went to Yale and he arrived there in the
age of 17 or 18 what was Yale like then
well yeah then was just beginning to
become a modern liberal arts university
like most universities in the 19th
century a Yale had been primarily a
university that taught people the
classics and and a few other things but
what hadn't changed was the the culture
of Yale in which the faculty and the
curriculum were sort of secondary to the
student activities and people measured
themselves by how successful they were
in sports or in the Yale Daily News or
maybe most of all getting into this into
the the club's into the the skullenbones
and the other secret societies and so
Luce had a very good academic record at
Yale but that's not what he really
talked about when he was writing or
letters to his parents or talking to his
friends everything was about making the
Yale Daily News and being the president
of the Yale Daily News which he didn't
which he failed to do and in the end
most of all being elected to Skull and
Bones which he which which did happen
for him the first part of your book is
almost a dual biography it describes
Lucis friendship and competition with a
very brilliant content
for a Briton Hatton was very different
from him yet they form a historic
collaboration and partnership how did
that happen Time Inc if there had not
been Britain Hatton
maybe there wouldn't have been won
without loose to the two of them met in
their first year in Harry's first year
at Hotchkiss hadn't had been there one
year before and they became friends they
had shared interests a both wanted to be
writers they both wanted to be wanted to
work on the newspaper when they went to
Yale they remained very close friends
partners collaborators rivals they they
competed with each other and everything
healing the the Yale Daily News and then
some years later competing to be
president of the Yale Daily News which
hadn't won to his great disappointment
ii now have his background with quite
different from loses also his character
and personality he grew up in an
upper-middle class but prosperous family
in Brooklyn
I loved baseball he went to local
schools and then when he sent off when
he was sent off to Hotchkiss it was the
first time he really had been out of the
the world of his family and he had a lot
of confidence and a lot of enthusiasm
Luce started out as a rather shy figure
at Hotchkiss
you have to imagine this this young man
who had never lived in the United States
and suddenly there he was in Hotchkis
with these sort of sophisticated if not
necessarily brilliant students from
wealthy families from around the country
he didn't know anything he didn't know
anything about America except what he'd
read he didn't know the slang he didn't
know the jokes he didn't know the the
customs not much you know and now the
two of them had ninh loose formed a
partnership and as you described at a
remarkably early age actually conceived
at least the the foundations of what
became Time magazine talked a little bit
about how they did that and also what
the state of journalism of newspapers
and magazines were like in the period
after World War one
when this remarkable magazine was
invented the stories about where the
idea came from and it's not clear which
of them was true maybe all of them are
true one story is that which i think is
probably correct they were working
together on the Yale Daily News and it
was during the war during World War one
and they decided to do a to introduce to
the Yale Daily News a digest of the
day's news of the world's news not the
not the Yale news but the world's news
and that was something completely new to
to the Yale Daily years later the
Harvard Crimson started a a feature
called the real world which is the same
wasn't the same thing so I think that
was part of what helped them think about
a news magazine although I don't think
they had really come up with the idea at
that point when they when they went off
to the military and they were sent from
from Yale to
Fort Jackson I in South Carolina I can't
remember they were training these young
men from the south and this is another
story that is very very often repeated
that they they were struck by how little
these young men from the south from the
rural South how little they knew about
the world and so that that's another
story maybe a little bit more
mythologized than the others that they
realized that there were so many people
who just didn't have any access to the
news and they thought they might provide
it but I think the real story was not
about creating a magazine to educate
uneducated rural people what they really
wanted to do was to create a news or
news venue that would serve what they
called busy people middle-class people
professional people who were being drawn
into a kind of nationalized world of the
middle-class who needed now to know more
about the world and about the country
than the U student they couldn't get by
any longer just by knowing local news
and loosin hadn't came to the conclusion
that there was no there was nothing that
would provide ordinary people busy
ordinary middle-class people with
serious news about the world
so time was meant to be comprehensive
would pull together news from all areas
of the world and all categories of news
but it would also be short and it would
be lively and it's writing idiosyncratic
as well and he's supposed to be able to
read it in an hour from cover to cover
and they assumed maybe correctly that
many readers did that they would just
pick it up and they would read it all
the way through writers some of whom
became household names well in the
beginning none of the writers were
household names including Hadden and
Luce they were kids who were just out of
college out of Yale mostly about also
from Harvard and Princeton and Columbia
and other University Ivy League
universities and none of them were any
older than loosen Hadden were I mean
they were 24 when the first issue of the
magazine came out so none of these
people originally were well-known people
over time as time became so
extraordinarily successful and later
fortune and life and ultimately Sports
Illustrated they began to hire major
writers not so much for time because
time was very formulaic and the really
good writers didn't want to write for
time
but fortune for example James Agee and
Dwight MacDonald and Archibald MacLeish
and many other very eminent writers
similarly in life and even in Sports
Illustrated William Faulkner wrote from
for Sports Illustrated John Steinbeck
did it was a real magnet to to writers
partly because they paid very well but
partly because these were probably the
most read magazines in the country the
circulation of Time magazine at its peak
can you give us some idea and compare it
to magazines today Time magazine today
versus Time magazine in its peak period
well I think they don't know what Time
magazine circulation is today it's down
considerably from what it was and maybe
10 or 15 years ago they started out with
a very small just a few thousand twenty
thirty thousand they very quickly grew
up into hundreds of thousands and by
World War two for example they had
reached somewhere around four million
now life at that point was more like 7
million and had maybe 20 million readers
so Mephisto
life was always the biggest had the
biggest circulation by far really a
photograph magazine it was a picture
magazine but it was also time you know
was a formulaic magazine and it was very
rigid in its structure and its writing
and life was a big wide open magazine
and even though it was mostly pictures
it was the first magazine that Luce had
where he could invite people to come and
write forward for them from outside the
company
it was also the first magazine to start
serializing books which was a big sort
of prestige item for the company the
first one that they did was the the
biography of this the autobiography of
Winston Churchill which is an incredibly
dull book and after the first selection
people stopped buying it but he but he
kept doing it and he would he did
Douglas MacArthur's memoirs which or at
least as boring as that maybe more
boring than Churchill's but somehow it
gave a kind of class and prestige to the
magazine and loose like that and
continue to do it Alan we hear a lot in
journalism today about business plans
these guys started what we would now
call a startup how did they make it work
where where did they find the money to
launch time in the early
well they started working on this when
they got out of college they kind they
sort of separated and hadn't did some
traveling he worked for the New York
world for about a year
loose went to Chicago we went to Oxford
for a year then went to Chicago took a
job in the Chicago Daily News lost the
job started looking around for business
opportunities and and then he got a
letter from Hadden who had found a job
at the baltimore news and it was going
to be a job for him and harry so loose
went he loose joined him in baltimore
was and it was a afternoon paper so they
would work at the paper in the morning
go back to the house that they were
renting or the part of the house that
they were renting and they would lie on
the floor and they'd cut up newspapers
and they'd start figuring out how to how
to organize a news magazine and they did
this for about eight or nine months and
then they moved up to New York left the
newspaper where they had a pretty good
job with pretty good pay and they
chucked it all moved to New York and
started planning the magazine and
started raising the money now as it
turned out Luce was the only one of them
who was really able to raise money so he
did most of the money raising and hadn't
in the meantime was working primarily on
planning the magazine so Luce went
around mostly to Skull and Bones people
from Yale
not necessarily his contemporaries but
Skull and Bones is
I mean neither of us has that experience
but my sense of skull and bones is that
it's a lifelong affiliation across the
generations the secret societies that
yeah absolutely presidents have belonged
to it William F Buckley was a member so
and you drive in the book yes the bushes
you describe in the book how the network
they had was a kind of well-to-do
Protestant north-eastern never what we
would think of as the establishment with
time created really did it help us
create the idea of an establishment in
America it created the establishment but
it certainly was it certainly was
propelled forward by the establishment
it was establishment people as you say
Yale men from skullenbones no more
establishment than that and that's where
the money came from slowly and and
agonizingly slowly too loose and loose
of course who had no money of his own
and really envied the rich people that
he had met at Hotchkiss and Yale and he
couldn't understand why they wouldn't
give him more money he felt you know
they've got so much money what what harm
would it do for them to part with a
little bit of it for us
of course there are thousands of people
who think that way to raise $100,000
which would been a lot of money in in
1923 and they got up to about 85
thousand basically with a few big gifts
from the Harkness family
big Yale family and very high power a
very very wealthy family and three
members of the Harkness family among
them gave providing $35,000 and that got
them up to more or less where they
thought they needed to be to get started
and they just decided they were going to
go ahead and do it and hope the money
would come in henry luce become wealthy
they had become prosperous I would say
by 1925 1926 two or three years after
after the magazine began now I guess
more to the point he became prosperous
when he got married because he was
married he married a woman named Lila
Hut's whose father actually stepfather
was a very wealthy man and her mother it
wasn't gonna let her little baby live in
some walk-up flat in New York and made
sure that they lived in a comfortable
townhouse with a with servants and so
even before they made money of their own
they were living as wealthy people and
then you know bye-bye 1926-27 they they
were wealthy themselves not yet
spectacularly wealthy as they later
became but very comfortably wealthy Time
magazine was published in New York City
as it still is where we are having this
interview how visible and influential a
figure how public a figure did Henry
Luce become in New York City what kind
of life did he live here his life
changed significantly he was known as an
important person by the early 30s
because Time magazine was flourishing
fortune had come out so most people in
New York especially people in journalism
knew who he was and knew he was
successful and powerful and he didn't
get around that much didn't like to go
to parties although he did go to them
occasionally with his with his wife and
the fact that he went to these parties
was the the key in fact to this
transformation of his life because it
was at one of these parties that he met
a young woman named Claire booth Brokaw
a widow wealth a wealthy widow who had
been the managing editor of Vanity Fair
a magazine you once worked for and they
met at a at a ball at the Waldorf
Astoria and they met again at a ball at
the Waldorf Astoria and at the the I
think the third time they met each other
at a party he had some kind of epiphany
and decided that this woman in whose
presence he had been for maybe two hours
in his entire life he decided he was in
love with her who's going to divorce his
wife and marry her and his first wife he
had two young children by his first wife
they were about twelve and nine at the
time he was a you know a presbyterian a
missionary son the clergyman's son it
was an incredibly wrenching decision for
him but he was determined and they after
about a year and a half of her getting
into him getting a divorce and her you
know taking off to Europe to avoid
scandal they got married in late 1935 I
just at the moment when Clare Boothe
Luce was becoming a successful
playwright so that marriage turned them
into a highly visible couple at the play
she wrote Alan
she wrote well she wrote a
a play her first play was called abide
by me and it was a sort of savage play
about her first husband who had died and
it was not a successful play but then
shortly after their marriage he wrote a
play called the women which was a huge
success and of course has been a movie
and it's been revived on Broadway
sensationally successful play and it's a
play about women being treated badly by
men and it was written in the immediate
aftermath of a traumatic dinner that she
had with a group of people for a group
of men from Time Inc who were lecturing
Harry about how he shouldn't allow
Claire to drive her away from the
company it treated Claire as if she were
the obstacle to his work in creating
Life magazine Claire had actually come
up with an idea of a picture magazine
when she was at Vanity Fair and she
proposed it to Conde Nast her boss and
and even proposed a title for it life
this is in 1932 four years before life
began the Life magazine began
I don't think that this was the reason
they called it life and I don't think
it's the reason that the loose started
the picture magazine he was thinking
about doing this well before he met
Claire but she thought not surprisingly
that she should she would have a role in
Life magazine maybe even be the editor
of Life magazine given her experience
women editors at Time magazine or writer
no no women have editors no women
writers only women at at time were
clerical people and researchers the
first woman not in that category was
Margaret bourke-white the photographer
who was hired to take pictures for
fortune and then later for a lot for
life so the idea of Claire becoming an
editor or even just a writer for life
was almost inconceivable to people in
the company and she felt betrayed and I
think that was that was sort of the end
the possibility of a really strong
marriage for the two of them this is
just a few months after their after
their wedding and this created a rift
between them that was never really
resolved did they stay married
they stayed married for the rest of
their lives for the rest of his life but
they spent most of their time apart
after the first couple of years even in
the first couple of years it just it was
for almost from the beginning of failed
marriage
and and yet they stayed together because
they both got so much about out of out
of being married to one another so much
fame so much prestige so influence and
they both they enhanced each other's
fame and she went on to have a political
career of some consequence she did she
was a Republican member of Congress the
House of Representatives for two terms
during World War two she was then the
ambassador to Italy in the 1950s when
Eisenhower was president Luce spent
about half his time in Rome with her it
was probably the the the time in their
marriage where they were closest when
they were in Rome together at the
Embassy but he was having affairs at
home while she was in Rome and and she
had had many affairs as well yes she was
a considerable figure editor playwright
politician ambassador not many women in
in that era could come close to her
achievements they told me once when
their surveys done of the most
influential and important women in
America that she had kind of been
overlooked because she wasn't identified
with feminism of a later era sort in
fact she was one of the most
accomplished and important women of her
time with an enormous ly influential
what we've mentioned politics what were
Henry Lewis's politics like well you
didn't have much politics at the
beginning he had he had opinions and
they were sort of ordinary elite Ivy
League sort of opinions well no well
actually he voted for Alfred Smith in
1928 when Hoover we don't ran against
Hoover he was I think it's the first of
all that he cast he was in bivolo about
whether to vote for Hoover or Roosevelt
in 1932 and he voted for Hoover just
because he thought it wouldn't make any
difference and they might as well just
you know keep person who's the person
who's experienced there I had no idea
that Roosevelt would be the Dynamo that
he would become but gradually he became
disillusioned with the Roosevelt and
especially in the the late 30s when Luce
was becoming a very passionate advocate
for more aid to Britain more involvement
of the United States in the coming war
and then of course after 1939 the war
itself and he hated Roosevelt for two
reasons one he believed that Roosevelt
wasn't moving fast enough and decisively
enough towards supporting Britain and
getting America into the war
secondly when the war began there was
already a feud between them on various
things that he had published in Time
magazine a relationship of any kind
whether they they saw each other
periodically not a lot but they were
never friends and when the war broke out
when after Pearl Harbor Roosevelt issued
an order that publishers could not take
transport to the war fronts and Luce
believed that this was targeted directly
at him and it was probably right
although I'm sure that Colonel McCormick
the head of the Chicago Tribune who was
also covered by this sub I'm sure they
were just dissipated
hated Roosevelt even much much more than
Luce did but Luce hated him pretty well
when when Roosevelt died he said to one
of his colleagues
I never said anything terrible about him
after he died in magazines but he said
to one of his colleagues it is my duty
to keep hating him and that's part of
what made him a Republican that he was
that he disliked Roosevelt so much and
he disliked parts but not all of the New
Deal but it's also I think that he was
sort of naturally Republican given the
world he'd grown up in and the people
that that he knew and
so the you know the the turning point I
think in his life as a highly political
person was the Wilkie campaign in 1940
and he he was smitten I would say by
Wilkie Wendell Willkie was a fairly
famous and very wealthy utilities
executive in in the 30s and he got into
a battle with the New Deal when there
was a antitrust law tasked for to
managing utilities and he began
campaigning against what the New Deal
was doing and Russell Davenport who was
a an editor for Fortune magazine and
less an employee of Luce got to know
Wendell Willkie and began to think this
guy should be could should be president
and he introduced into loose and loose
was just mesmerized by him and it was
one of these great crushes that he had
on people he thought were great men you
know others were Theodore Roosevelt who
whom he'd never met and Wilkie Chiang
kai-shek Churchill you know there was a
group of Douglas MacArthur there were
these people that he just found he was
just overwhelmed by them well he was not
a political figure himself never but in
1940 he got the Republican nomination
having conceived as a Democrat and
having previously previously been a
Democrat how instrumental were the loose
publications in his getting the
nomination hard to say there were there
were other groups that were also
organizing behind Wilkie and promoting
him but certainly in the media the the
loose magazines were the most steadfast
in promoting Wilkie putting him on the
cover of time putting on the cover of
life timing issues to hit the convention
right at the right and right at the
right moment I mean it was no secret
that he was campaigning for Wilkie
through his magazines and I think that
was a significant part of what made him
successful
we should probably clarify that Britain
hadn't had died by this point yes that's
a very important he died in 1930 or 31
29 29
Jan 4 his 31st birthday and that was a
big turning point in Lucy's life it was
a turning point first because he lost
his partner and his most important
friend on the other hand they have not
been getting getting along with one of
their terribly well lucid but dream I
mean hey I hadn't have been drinking a
lot had been absent a lot was becoming a
kind of distraction to the people around
him so he was he was shattered by his
death but didn't take him long to step
in and take over
it really became Lucis anticline and
from then on it was Lucis company and
nobody else's now Alan you mentioned
that Luce times the publication of
issues to help to coincide with Wilkie's
campaign he also had a staff of writers
and some of them I assume are very
independent-minded
did they some of the famous writers
you've mentioned in Fortune magazine or
Time magazine share Lucis politics
fortune had started out as a kind of
lefty magazine it was okay it was a
business magazine but it was it wasn't
business people who were writing for it
it was people like as I mentioned
earlier Dwight MacDonald and Archibald
MacLeish oh yeah yeah very very liberal
I and liberal editors I meet was ends
and they were writing about capitalism
at a time when most intellectuals didn't
think much of capitalism so it was so it
was a pretty you know wasn't dumb it
wasn't a screed but it was subtly a kind
of skeptical magazine writing about
business and outlining its faults and
not all not all the pieces but quite a
lot loose got fed up with this and by
critical ISM this is a business magazine
it's going to be read by businessmen you
know this isn't you know this isn't a
political magazine and so he reorganized
the magazine and it became a more
traditional magazine although still
somewhat more literary than others
Russell Davenport who was for a while
the editor of fortune and who was the
man who met Wilkie was the person from
Time Inc who moved into the Wilkie
campaign he took a leave of absence and
he was Wilkie speechwriter
and Luce was thrilled because it not
only because he thought what Devonport
would help Wilkie but also because it
gave him a an entryway into a Wilkie's
campaign and he wrote speeches for for
Wilkie almost every day he wrote
something to him advising him London to
do this and to do that and he would
write speeches for him which Wilkie
usually didn't use although once or
twice he did raise questions then or now
having to do with ethics was would this
be acceptable in today's journalism no
and it shouldn't have been acceptable in
in that day's journalism and wouldn't
have been in many many journalistic play
organizations Luce had this vision of
these magazines as a kind of personal
property he owned it I mean in reality
he was the majority shareholder but he
controlled the magazine and he felt that
it that he was entitled to use his
magazine to support the ideas that he
believed in that's not what most
newspapers think when they think about
how to organize what they write in in
newspapers nor in most other
journalistic magazines so this is
something that distinguishment to Time
magazine and and life and fortune so
forth
from other magazines and newspapers of
his time about conflicts that arose over
political questions for instance between
Luce and theater or white you know many
of our viewers are familiar with white
is the author of the classic making of
the president series but he also began
a loose journalist a China correspond
that's exactly right
Teddy White who was a scholarship a
graduate of Harvard very close to John
King Fairbank the famous China American
China historian he won a Harvard
scholarship that sent him to to China
and then he found his way eventually
into the China time Time magazine Bureau
and that's where he met Luce Luce came
visiting in 1940 and and Harry Teddy
White was there they became great
friends and he was already a brilliant
journalist but he was a little like
loose he had opinions too and he had no
no reservations about inserting his
opinions into what he wrote and so when
Luce started getting his dispatches from
white he loved them because they were
filled with opinions that were identical
to his own but gradually white became
disillusioned with Shanghai Shaq and
with the cool mint on the Chinese
government and he began to become more
and more critical of Chiang kai-shek and
rightly so I mean the regime was riddled
with corruption and incompetence and
Luce refused to accept any negative
visions of of shang-chi shek and over
time it took a while but over time he
became so frustrated with white then he
fired him and this was right at the end
of the war and Teddy white of course
went off to a brilliant career writing
books and being a freelance writer
reading is up there was another
interesting political journalist who is
in the middle of that Freitas - between
white and Henry Luce Whittaker Chambers
had a role at Time magazine yes you've
written so brilliantly Whittaker
Chambers joined time maybe you maybe you
remember I can't remember what year 1939
there was some right right right right
around the beginning of the war and he
started out writing book reviews and
Luce read one of them
and came down and said this is the best
book review anybody has ever written for
Time magazine and within a few months he
was not only a the premier book reviewer
but he was running the whole back of the
book the whole art section in the back
of the book basically writing it all
himself and he was pretty much despised
by his colleagues because he was such a
strange man as you know better than I
and he was so obsessed with communism
broken with communism and then found a
public life and time that's right and he
was haunted by this experience and not a
crusade of his own would you say the
crusade of his own to fight communism to
persuade the world of the dangers of
communism and also to protect himself
because he was afraid of being
assassinated by communist agents Jason
wasn't crazy having that there there
were people who were assassinated
into the China debate why was China so
important we know Luce grew up there but
why did the fate of China become so
important in this period what chambers
really wanted to be was the head of the
foreign news section of time and when
the previous foreign news editor moved
to London to cover news from there Luce
made him the the editor of the foreign
news section of the magazine
and just as he had done the in the back
of the book part he started writing
pretty much the whole for a new section
and writing or rewriting more to the
point he would rewrite almost all the
stories that had especially those that
had anything to do with Russia and
communism and it was this is what came
to be known in in the Time Inc world as
the Chamber's war because most of the
reporters came to despise him and
thought he was a terrible reactionary
now in many ways it turns out that loose
that chambers had a better understanding
of communism than most of they did most
of them did but he was very much out of
the loop of what most of the journalists
in the timing company had so he he wrote
he wrote for quite a while foreign news
and he had he was a it was not a healthy
man and he had periods of great illness
I had heart trouble and he stepped down
from foreign news of West Point and and
that was the beginning of the end of his
time at at time but it he was a major
figure in the magazine for quite some
time
relationship
Earth's Republican president in that era
Dwight Eisenhower I he was a he was very
very favorably disposed towards
Eisenhower even before he met him and he
was dazzled by him you know in much the
same way he'd been Tesla but I will be
even though they were very different
personalities but mostly what what made
him so feel so close to Eisenhower is
that Eisenhower set out to court him and
he would invite him to the White House
invite him to Gettysburg he would write
him letters he really believed that and
it's so different from Roosevelt who
when Lewis wrote something he didn't
like Roosevelt would make a sharp public
criticism of him whereas Eisenhower if
they agreed with it if they disagreed
about anything he would call him in and
talk it over with him
and he would see his position and would
try to explain to him why he couldn't
sell it and he loose you know held his
peace any colleagues of loose who then
were participated in the Eisenhower
administration as they might have done
at staffs had been elected yes
[Music]
and what's-his-name Hughes - Emmett
Hughes who was a life writer left to
work for Eisenhower for the Eisenhower
campaign in 1952 and a couple of the
Democrats in the magazine the magazine
left to work for Stevenson which
irritated loose but he realized he
couldn't say no to them if he had said
said yes to Hughes so there was a
sprinkling of of timing people in the
Eisenhower administration but loose
particularly treasurer his own personal
relationship with Eisenhower which
probably meant a lot more to Toulouse
than it did to Eisenhower Allen you've
sketched out so well the arc of the of a
journalist who became extraordinarily
powerful close to greatness and a great
figure himself do we see anything
parallel in journalism today it is there
a Time magazine in at our moment that
has that kind of prestige and reach and
influence or is this have have we passed
the point where that can happen again
well I think we're in a period of very
very significant and maybe traumatic
transition that we have
musical accompaniment here and I think I
mean clearly the news magazines as they
were at Time Newsweek us news are
nothing like what they were Newsweek is
is out being offered and is you know
very possibly going to disappear us news
is really no longer a magazine it's a
website of stuffs with some news and it
publishes magazine like things that rank
colleges and universities that's
basically pretty much what they publish
and now and time is still managing but
it's no longer a news magazine in the
sense that it used to be I think the
most prestigious news magazine now is
the Economist
very yeah British publication that has
this a significant public significant
circulation in the United States as well
its circulation is relatively small it's
a million but it's it's subscriptions
are very expensive seventy-five dollars
and they work on a shoestring and they
have not very much advertising but they
get by and it has it's a very
influential magazine time is
experimenting with features and
you know sort of personal views of their
are their writers long form journalism
very little summaries of the news
anymore
and it's you know it's managing but it's
it's not nearly as influential as it
used to be and so might this be then the
end of an era in journalism and print
journalism there's I think we're nearing
the end of a lot of print journalism and
that's the the the fear at least for me
is not that the New York Times for
example might soon be read mainly on the
iPad and that wouldn't bother me if it's
still the New York Times my fear is that
no one has learned how to monetize
material that goes under the web there's
lots of magazines and lots of
advertisements on the web but the the
rates are much lower than they are for
print and it's it's expensive to run a
web version of a newspaper as well as a
print version of a newspaper and so the
New York Times just to choose a random
institution is basically publishing two
newspapers
neither of which is very profitable
anymore or the web site isn't profitable
this is it you know I don't know what
the percentage is now last I heard was
producing about 10% of the advertising
revenue yes that's about right
and you know as you know there have been
staff cutbacks and other things and yet
it's still a great newspaper and that
that's what we have to hope can survive
but what what needs to happen is revenue
that makes it possible for newspapers
and magazines to pay for pay journalists
to pay for reporters and without that I
think the the nation in the world would
be impoverished and and damaged
significantly mentioned for instance the
detailed massive foreign news that Time
magazine presented to readers so we're
their bureaus throughout the capitals of
the world at the beak of Time Magazine's
in the beginning that wasn't the case in
the beginning it was a few people
sitting in an office in New York
rewriting things from The Times and
other newspapers by the mid 30s they
were developing a repertory 'el staff
and by the beginning of World War two
they had one of the biggest cohorts of
correspondents in the world they had
they had correspondents in every
covering the war it was one of the
biggest news organizations in the world
at that point probably not as big as
Reuters or some of the nits wouldn't but
bigger than any newspaper at the time
world war two was really the high-water
mark of the Time Inc news and news
magazines that those magazines came to
serve a very significant change in the
culture and the journalistic culture of
the United States and it served that
that culture very well for 40 years but
today
those magazines either don't exist
anymore life is gone or they are
struggling magazines that are very
different from what they used to be and
I I just don't I just don't see yet what
the path is from these struggling print
organizations to lucrative web
organizations
American Century of journalism then may
have come to an end I think so I think
you know there are there remnants of it
but they don't have anything like the
influence or the money that they've had
in the past
now Time Warner is one of the biggest
media corporations in the world so it's
not as if Time Inc and its successors
haven't created a powerful corporation
that will survive it's very lucrative
Airy successful corporation but the
magazine part of it is is the weakest
part and in fact there's talk of Time
Warner selling off the magazines
Alan Brinkley thanks so much for being
our guest today - congratulations on
extraordinary biography thank you sir
Alan Brinkley the author of the
publisher Henry Luce and his American
Century